so this is the story we pulled it up uh
so people have the one love bracelets
and symbols and cutter was like no you
you can't wear those things and people
are all shocked and surprised they're
not allowed to do it it's the craziest
thing to me they can't even drink at
this point they banned alcohol which
which was more of a controversy which is
great they shouldn't be drinking alcohol
it's horrible for you it's horrible for
your brain it shrinks your brain but
should they be banned from drinking well
this is their their religion this is
their culture right and if we want to be
you know respectful of them this is how
they do it do it so so this is the fine
line that a lot of people are playing in
but that's more of a controversy than
the the migrant slave workers that were
dying building the stadiums which that
has nothing to do with religion like
that's just the fact that they well it
depends because some religions are okay
with with with slavery more than others
you know there's also particular scripts
in you know according to the Quran uh
there's particular scripts that are you
know like pushed for an application
passage from the Quran on in the opening
ceremy ceremony along with like Morgan
Freeman and then this double amputee
YouTuber from Qatar and the whole
ceremony just seemed so satanic and
globalist and creepy it like sent chills
down my spine I I was so disgusting poor
Morgan Freeman how much did they pay him
to do it I mean and he was he was lip
syncing it so badly uh speak Arabic or
something no no they like he had this
monologue that was playing around the
stadium but he wasn't saying it live he
was lip syncing to it and it was really
badly done and it was just like the
whole thing was a mix of cringy and evil
see me I just I'm saying like the
alcohol thing I think people should be
allowed to drink alcohol I think uh I
you know I think there was some special
process you had to go through like you
had to apply to be able to drink at the
stadium right well you can still drink
at bars outside the stadium you just
can't drink on the actual right but my
point is just this is like kind of
waking people up so like hey wait a
minute what's going on with this country
uh yeah there are women who have been
raped and then imprisoned for being
raped yes like I'm that's crazy
because we overturned Roe v Wade we're
being called out as as having Draconian
laws against women's rights it's not
even the same playing field like it's
completely you should see you should see
what Saudi Arabia is doing to the
Shiites especially with all that public
hangings that they've been doing and and
if you look up public hanging Saudi
Arabia right now you're going to see
that there's an influx of this
especially right now which is which is
absolutely crazy but this is our one of
one of our biggest allies that we're
funneling all these weapons and arms to
and having a coalition that's bombing
Yemen right now working with of course
Al-Qaeda Rebels which a lot of people
want to ignore but even the Associated
Press admitted the United States
Coalition is on the side of Al Qaeda and
they do little PR Ops where of course
the U.S troops and the Saudi Arabian
troops come in and then they literally
call Al Qaeda be like hey guys leave and
then Al Qaeda comes back in and conquers
the territory did you guys see the uh I
think it was Babylon B article Taliban
quits Twitter protest of trump being
reinstated that was good those guys are
funny
yeah well when you take a look at some
of these countries there was a uh it's
surprising to me I was going back to
what I was saying about uh cutter there
was a story it might have been Dubai is
Dubai where's Dubai in the Emirates a
lot of these these countries have
similar rules uh similar laws there was
a woman who was on a work trip with a
male colleague and they they hooked up
in a room and then they were like oh
you're under arrest like that's illegal
you cohabitating there was another story
where a woman was on a work trip and
like some guy went to a room and raped
her so she called the police and they
said okay you're under arrest for you
know sex outside of marriage and she was
like what then she goes to prison like
it's shocking to me how they're American
people and European individuals who go
to these countries seemingly believing
that they have the same values as the
west and they don't they know they
believe that they're just in jail they
rely on Western self-hatred
to avoid responsibility for this that's
what it is with the World Cup westerners
can't call out human rights violations
in this country because westerners are
supposed to hate themselves for their
own so-called human rights violations
and truly like the overturning of Roe v
Wade is not even close to uh the the
laws you're talking about in fact our
biggest human rights violation in my
opinion is the fact that we have
abortion in this country at all yeah we
kill babies John where are you where do
you draw the line when it comes to
either respecting the culture or pushing
them to change and calling them out for
being wrong how do you navigate this
crazy Minefield that is uh that is a
very good question I think that I I
notice a very disturbing tendency for
this like blind American patriotism
George W bush style wave in the flag
which I love I'm a patriot but I see
like this very sad phenomenon now where
you've got like middle-aged dads for
example and they're coming home and
they're watching the news they're in
their recliner and they're hearing a
story about how you know women are being
raped in the Middle East or these
terrible things are happening and then
their you know Sun comes in and they're
like okay Dad we have to go to the
pharmacy to pick up my hormones they're
just like be right there son they're
like those Muslims are real Savages how
barbaric are they and it's like look
rape murder abuses of women this stuff
is as old as human history what is new
and what is especially evil is what's
going on in this country which is now
you are taking children and you are
exploiting them to very evil things you
are doing the most evil thing that could
be done to them which I'm sure we'll get
into in the uh the after segment and
that is new nowhere else in the world is
that happening except the west and when
the West goes and invades other
countries maybe for financial reasons
maybe for oil ultimately what they're
trying to do is introduce things like
feminism introduce things like gender
ideology or even like with our
immigration policy for example I don't
want to live in the Middle East I don't
want to live in Russia I don't want to
live anywhere like that terrible
countries but at least those will still
be given to their descendants whereas it
is the official policy of Western
countries to bring in people from the
third world oftentimes from Muslim
countries to replace the native
population nation of that country so
maybe their countries suck but at least
they'll be able to hand that down to
their children whereas the West can't
say the same so not only do we not have
our heritage we're being taught to hate
that we don't even have our future
because our kids aren't going to have
the same country that we had and also if
the kids even are allowed to be children
they're not going to be there
you know what I think I think a big
component of this is that the right has
a longer memory than the left or the
left is just outright lying which is
probably the case uh this happened at
Tucker Carlson he was talking about this
idea uh that's Democrats are bringing in
immigrants
to you know uh I guess
expand the population as it were Chuck
Schumer literally said this like
recently he said Americans don't have
enough kids so we need I think it was
Schumer said this right he's like we got
to bring in more immigrants and it's
like okay you know or we as a country
can be like hey maybe people should have
kids too like I'm I'm down for
immigration done legally and through a
normal legal process and then if we're
concerned about population expansion how
about instead of saying abort your kids
and sterilize them you say okay maybe
some people should have kids and we
could have immigrants too like what's
wrong with this Tucker mentions this
that Democrats have explicitly stated
they want to bring in
uh immigrants because they vote they
vote Democrat when when immigrants get
naturalized and become citizens they
typically vote Democrat and when they
get added to the census as legal
residents or I guess even non non-legal
residents that counts towards the census
and gives congressional power and
presidential electoral power to these
two states Tucker Carlson says this that
all of a sudden the media forgets that
they were advocating for this very thing
that Schumer advocated for this very
thing and accuse him of being a white
supremacist conspiracy theorist yeah and
that's the problem is like you know you
can you will have the types who want to
make it like this explicitly racial
issue and there is a component to it
that is that but really what it boils
down to is like the people who have the
deepest incentive in preserving this
country conserving this country are
conservatives
um and also people who are white because
this country was virtually like 90 white
up until 1965 when they restructured the
Immigration Act so if you look at all
the people who are going to want to keep
things the same yeah they're going to be
by majority white people that doesn't
mean that there can't be other groups of
people who can't want to conserve the
country keep it the same but they do
have an explicit incentive to import
people who are not white from these
third world countries because they're
not going to really care about things
changing you know and oftentimes they
fail to assimilate even where they'll
come and they still want to wave the
Mexican flag or the flag of wherever
they come from and it's like they like
America insofar as it presents economic
opportunities to them or insofar as it
presents other types of opportunities
but they don't really value it as like a
home or something and we're so desperate
for people to love this country because
we're so used to people [ __ ] on it
that then they want to have people oh
well they're waving the flag so they're
just like us we can sing Sweet Caroline
at the baseball game and get drunk
they're just as American as we are and
it's like it's not that simple yeah I
think this is their path towards world
domination
Joe Biden recently announced climate
reparations do you guys see this yeah a
billion was a billion dollars I think so
and uh a lot of people on the right
missed the point they come out and they
say this this climate change stuff is
bunk and the you know oh and Joe Biden's
giving away our money
you know why he did it
the concern right now is that the brics
nations are expanding the world economic
Forma says said Brix plus is the future
people like Joe Biden want the Petro
dollar to remain in the future
how do you maintain the Petro dollar
you give the money to people and tell
them you say I'm going to give you money
then guess what happens these people say
I have this money it's valuable you give
to other countries you give it to
Pakistan for gender studies then brick
says hey hey use the ruble or the or the
one and they go no no I have all these
dollars they're valuable
by giving out this money
the US is trying to force other
countries to use the dollar and retain
it and maintain confidence in it that's
the real incentive because if it ever
comes to the point where the Petro
dollar ceases to exist or it is no
longer the reserve currency Americans
are in for a very rude awakening about
the manufacturing base in this country
and the things that they don't get from
here so your computers are gone your
clothes are gone your shoes are gone
your cars are gone good luck
yeah that's interesting because like you
say what you will about China but they
understand that with economies
production equals prosperity and this
country's economy is based on like a
bunch of really weird things we've got
like this debt-based money system uh
fiat currency usury you know these weird
like I.T jobs and middle managers but
like we don't actually make anything in
this country how we used to and with the
pandemic and everything that really
showed where our weaknesses are and uh
until we start to bring back some of
that manufacturing capacity we're just
basically like riding a wave that's
eventually going to crash well this
happened and I don't think there's
there's any way we could go back to what
you have been describing ever since of
course Richard Nixon and Henry Kissinger
went to China and opened up China to the
world AKA made a deal with them saying
hey we're just going to take all the
factory jobs give you them for cheap
slave labor goods and we're just going
to keep printing more money here the
larger question is how much more money
could we be printing here and there's
also going to be a lot of significant
economic problems not just with all this
crazy money printing but more
importantly what's happening right now
in China with their zero sickness policy
is absolutely insane and will have a
very detrimental effect on the American
public mainly because they're not going
to be producing they're not working
they're locking millions and millions of
people down into their own buildings
without any food even in many instances
where people are dying and killing
themselves because they're so sick of
the lockdowns which are being patrolled
by drones that are literally flying
overhead from them surveilling them and
watching every single one of their moves
as they have to live on a QR Code system
and and now China also is stockpiling a
lot of gold they're also decoupling a
lot from the US dollar so they're making
a lot of very significant moves away
from the U.S consumerist system that is
dependent on their slave labor and I
don't think they actually you know
understand the larger consequences of it
because they're prioritizing a zero
sickness policy which is absolutely
nonsensical I think it was one person
that died in China because of this
sickness yeah yeah well you know yeah we
say sickness because again
you see the video of I think there was
like a theme park and then all of a
sudden the police announced there was a
there was a covid Disney World in in
China people were locked in there unless
they had a QR code that approved yeah
they were stuck in Disneyland in China
so this shows you the level of just
control freak Insanity that that these
people are willing to go through again
Bill Gates compliments this he says
China's doing an amazing job Bill Gates
is advising the Chinese government here
so to me what's happening in China is a
larger beta test to what they want to
roll out globally against everyone and
that is total control and that's what we
saw from the G20 that's what we saw from
cope uh 27 all plans to create a system
a social credit system a central bank
digital currency system a system where
of course you get followed around by
drones and need a QR code of compliance
just to exist in society and I refuse to
live in that kind of society I think
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time